SHIVA SHARIF BIDABADI: This system which has
been designed for this specific study is a kind
of a device using three separate IMU devices placed
in three color coded 3D printed boxes.
And the sensors will be attached to the different sections of the lower limb.
For example, in this case, thigh, shank, and foot off the subject.
And the data from this device will be captured simultaneously
to the receiver dongle that connects to the laptop
and collects the data from the devices.
Having this device attached to the body section,
we can provide some information about the movement
of that section of the body.
For example, angle of the thigh during the walking trial.
For example, positive and negative movements in the whole gait cycle.
The sensors in the devices are Inertial Measurement Units
which is a kind of sensor that consists of accelerometer gyroscope,
and magnetometer in a single unit that provides a good range of information
about the movement.
Each three devices have the same sensor inside them, just numbered.
Accelerometer actually reads the acceleration of the device.
for the angle of velocity in different directions, x, y, and z.
And a magnetometer also looks for the magnetic field in the area.
It could get noise easily by any magnetic field near the sensor.
But in general, the readings that we're going
to have from the inertial measurement unit is the acceleration in three axes,
the magnetic field in three axis and also the angle
of velocity in three different axis.